Bước tí, với khách sạm không cách nông tinh mặc biệt,
mà hai mình cần bệnh trực bệnh bơi xin vừa,
đi cùng đó là bà khách sạm mới lắm tầm,
bình như tệ nghĩ hiện đạo,
mà có thể cũng ra đình trải nghiệm định mục dí băng trận hàng,
với hơi mấy muốn bước trải nghiệm và tương chính phòng xong rơi đã trên năng,
giúp thử rạm đúng điệu như người bạn sứ,
hay đám mạnh trong bệnh bối bối bối của năm sau xang trọng.
Thông ra nơi đây được tích kế thêm con két cao cấp,
bối tí biển cực phợp.
Sẵn xảy tư giúp mệnh tình như người bạn tình như người chói đây.
Không chỉ xa dưới xa ở nơi làm đe đặc cấp,
với lã sát sẩm sân của xa dưới tổ xí trải.
Ô đều ăn đúng như phà sức tã hợp sợp vệnh,
với những trải nghiệm bối bối xe trời dù thách tự tập đôi,
ra đình anh nhau là khí khách sạm bài bước trân.
Vì lã sát xa dưới bài biệt dưới đại mục kí lâu mẹ,
bây giờ điểm được tự ký thích,
phát có thể văn đồng này mới bước bỏng sẻ bộ,
để phát sức tã biệt.
Không lo đúng không bối ra ra điểm của chảy nhau.
Bởi bối trong nhà của nó sông là một cái trích không thể bỏng qua,
mấy trời phát thích của mẹ tình như bạn tây.
Vì lã sát của tụi chí khu kênh tình bên biệt.
Zó biệt mắt dưới.
Tình sống dưới giá chắc chắn sẽ đen gá cho bạn rử dụt chí vinh sầu.
Phát gái vụ trời mệt gì như người biệt.
Tối đến là chói nhau khám phát kinh đường,
hôm tựa ra chỉ thú vị, người với lã sát.
Có hoạt động sự tự văn đồng á.
Lê hộ được của chút chương miên á để trảy không dưới hả?
Chương miên đúng biết.
Vì lã sát là dưới phát chế vời văn khu.
Nếu có dưới hiểu, khi sau không dạm và các bạn đi ở đây đều được tụi
để chí chú, chúng chất nghĩ rất sợ thật, bó bạm là tình.
Lê có mạng đất tình một nơi vơ gần vừa xí,
để châu lắm, dị dự vơ bình vụ trời hết nất.
Tìvì lã sát xâm dư nó một lần chó không thể hợp gơ cho vô hẹn hại.